Let's do a little bit of a, I don't know,
talking sense on vaccination, because the
vaccination disinformation that is spreading
is absolutely ridiculous.
Now, I want to be very clear.
This is not a segment to correct medical misinformation
about vaccines.
Later today, we'll talk to Dr. Eric Topol
about the medical aspects of vaccination.
We've done that before.
So so this is not about, oh, the vaccine will
give you covid or Bill Gates will microchip
you.
We've debunked that stuff separately.
This is a segment about the political misinformation
about coronavirus vaccines.
Things like Trump delivered a vaccine or operation
warp speed is doing great thanks to America
for the vaccine, that type of stuff.
So this is going to be a great opportunity
to go over where we are today on vaccination.
And the bottom line is the first vaccine to
be approved.
The FDA by Pontac vaccine was developed by
two Turkish immigrants to Germany in Germany
very early in the pandemic before Donald Trump
did a thing about the coronavirus.
It had nothing to do with Trump.
It had nothing to do with the Trump administration,
period.
Donald Trump has bragged about how, thanks
to him, we developed vaccines faster than
ever before.
That has nothing to do with Donald Trump.
The reason we developed vaccines so quickly
is that the MRN, a platform for vaccines instead
of working on dead or weakened virus, works
by giving cells instructions for how to make
proteins that trigger an immune response.
That technology, by its nature, shortens the
vaccine development time.
That's why the vaccines, both in and out of
the U.S. were developed so quickly, has nothing
to do with Donald Trump.
So so in terms of development, there's very
little to even talk about regarding Donald
Trump.
Now, what does he have to do with Donald Trump
is vaccine distribution in the United States,
and that's been an absolute and total disaster.
No one remember that Donald Trump previously
promised us one hundred million vaccine doses
by the end of the year, last year, 2020.
We didn't get there.
More recently, the Trump administration promised
twenty million vaccinations by the end of
2020.
We did not get there.
And where we are today and Bloomberg has a
very good vaccine tracker, is that as of a
few hours ago, 13 million doses of the vaccine
have been distributed.
And that term, we're still unclear on distributed
means.
What exactly?
Only four million, four point three million
first doses have been injected.
And remember that you need two doses with
the current vaccines.
The second doses are just now starting.
So we were supposedly going to have twenty
million vaccinated by December 31st.
Instead, we have four point three million
partially vaccinated by January 5th.
This is an abject failure.
Now, it's not completely clear what the holdup
is, but this is going very much like testing.
They lied about testing early and they seem
to be lying about vaccines early as well.
So for things that actually have to do with
Trump, which are vaccination distribution,
it's a disaster.
There is one other aspect to this.
Vaccination is going to remain slower than
it has to be, thanks to Donald Trump.
As I told you last the week before last, in
late July, Trump turned down the opportunity
to buy another one hundred million doses from
Pfizer.
So Pfizer said, OK, well, you don't want them.
We'll sell them to other countries.
And that's exactly what they did.
So instead of getting another 100 million
doses in the first quarter of this year or
even in the second quarter of this year, Donald
Trump has now salvaged a purchase of one hundred
million more Pfizer doses from a future shipment
which are due to us by July 31.
We don't get those until July 31.
That means that those will not be injected
into people until August, September and October.
Utterly embarrassing and a total failure.
That's the real record of the Trump administration
on vaccines.
Great things have happened, including the
development of multiple effective vaccines
and and the start of a vaccination program.
None of that has to do with Trump where Trump
was involved, which is this early logistics
program.
It's been a failure.
It would be hilarious, except it is an utter
tragedy of cataclysmic proportions, which
is leading to unnecessary death.
Hopefully, President Joe Biden will be able
to accelerate vaccine distribution.
We'll have more about this on The David Pakman
Show Instagram page.
Find us there at David Pakman show.
You can find me on Instagram as well at David
Pakman.